se dirige-t-on vers un non-lieu dans le
scandale du chlordécone c'est en tout
cas ce que laissent penser les
déclarations du procureur de la
république rémy est dans la sphère des
empoisonnements au chlordécone qui ont
secoué la martinique et la guadeloupe
les problèmes de prescription existait
pour l'essentiel dès le dépôt des
plaintes il était nécessaire que la
justice pénale avec les moyens
d'investigation importants dont elle
dispose
contribuer avec d'autres à faire la
lumière sur les raisons de l'utilisation
du chlordécone en guadeloupe et en
martinique
le chlordécone est un insecticide
utilisé dans les champs de bananier
martiniquais et guadeloupéens entre 1972
et 1993 pour éliminer un insecte le
charançon du bananier en 1979 l' oms
place le chlordécone comme cancérigènes
possibles
plus de dix ans après en 1990 son
utilisation est interdite en france mais
en guadeloupe et en martinique elle va
se poursuivre jusqu'en 1993 notamment
grâce à des dérogations ministériel
résultat selon santé publique france
plus de 90% de la population adulte sur
ces 2 il est contaminé par le
chlordécone et on observe un taux
d'incidence du cancer de la prostate
parmi les plus élevés au monde en 2019
une commission d' enquête parlementaire
publie un rapport
il pointe la responsabilité de l'état
dans ce qui est qualifié de désastre
sanitaire et environnementale
l'état a fait subir des risques
inconsidérés au vu des connaissances
scientifiques de l'époque aux
populations et aux territoires de
guadeloupe et de martinique le maintien
de la production bananière a trop
souvent pris le pas sur la sauvegarde de
la santé publique et de l'environnement
en 2006 trois plaintes sont déposées par
des associations martiniquaise et
guadeloupéenne pour empoisonnement mise
en danger de la vie d'autrui et
administration de substances nuisibles
mais les faits dénoncés pour la plupart
étaient déjà prescrits selon la
législation de l'époque les délais de
prescription à l'aide trois ans pour les
délits à 10 pour les crimes
le dossier est malgré tout instruit
depuis 14 ans par le pôle santé publique
du tribunal judiciaire de paris
deux avocats de l'association médicale
de sauvegarde de langues
heureusement et de la santé ont annoncé
avoir déposé un mémoire auprès des juges
afin de contester la question de la
prescription
ils ont aussi indiqué vouloir déposer
plainte contre plusieurs anciens
ministres devant la cour de la justice
de la république pour avoir prolongé
l'autorisation d'utilisation du
chlordécone les avocats qui comptent
aussi sur la pression de la population
concernée par ce scandale
fin février cinq à dix mille personnes
se sont mobilisées dans les rues de fort
de france contre cette possible
prescription de nouveaux rassemblements
étaient organisés ce week end